[Music]
before the world was ever gripped by the
coronavirus
the global health security index rated
every country on its pandemic
preparedness
the average overall score across the
globe was 40.2 out of 100
while high-income countries had an
average score of 51.9
but the highest score of any country
head and shoulders above the rest
was the united states with a score of
83.5
rich strong and developed america was
supposed to be the shining example of
how to respond to a pandemic
should such a catastrophic situation
ever arise
now several months into that once
hypothetical worst case scenario
the illusion of america's readiness has
been thoroughly shattered
the us just surpassed a million
confirmed coronavirus cases
by far the most of any country and even
adjusting for population
the u.s still stands among the hardest
hit the reasons for this are many
delayed lockdowns lack of essential
protective equipment for hospitals
and perhaps most critically a dire lack
of testing
especially in the early stages of the
outbreak in the month after the us had
its first confirmed case
the u.s only tested around 3 000 people
by comparison in the month after their
first case
south korea tested a hundred thousand
and with much more data about who had
the virus
they were able to implement rigorous
contact tracing to identify the travel
of each confirmed case
and looking at the infection curves of
both countries it is not a coincidence
that south korea's curve flattens
relatively quickly
and america's does not the u.s has
ramped up testing since
then but it is still severely lagging
behind what is needed
to reopen the u.s by mid-may the number
of daily tests performed between now and
then should be as much as 700 000
and right now it is nowhere near that
you cannot find
a fire blindfolded yes it is a failing
let's admit it the main test in question
at the center of
all this chaos is called an rt pcr test
and something about it has crippled the
response of the most developed country
in the world
what is it about this test that has been
so problematic
and can scientists and biotech companies
rush to make something better
the current standard for coronavirus
testing is the reverse transcription
polymerase chain reaction
or rt-pcr test to test someone
you first have to swab deep into their
throat and nose to collect cells that
potentially have the virus
the sample is then added to a lysis
buffer which breaks open the cells
so that the viral rna can be extracted
if it is present
the viral rna is then amplified by
transcribing the rna to dna
using an enzyme called reverse
transcriptase and then allowing the dna
to replicate many times
then short fragments of dna that are
complementary to certain sections of the
viral dna are added
called primers these primers will attach
themselves to
target sections of the viral dna if it
is present in the sample
also added to the mix are small sections
of dna called reporters
which contain a fluorescent marker which
will bind to the dna near the primer
a polymerase enzyme then latches on
where a primer has bound to a strand of
dna
the enzyme moves along the strand adding
complementary nucleotides until the
strand is copied
when the polymerase reaches the reporter
sequence a fluorescent probe is released
creating an optical signal that the
strand has been copied
as more coronavirus genes get amplified
over time
the fluorescent lights glow brighter and
brighter you can't physically see the
fluorescence
so the rt-pcr machine records spikes on
a graph that tracks the glowing as it
gets brighter
revealing whether the sample contained
the coronavirus
negative results won't show the spikes
pcr tests have been around for decades
they are the gold standard for testing
viruses because the process is highly
sensitive
it can detect even a tiny amount of
virus in a sample
but pcr tests are not something that
every hometown hospital can do
any lab doing coronavirus pcr tests
needs federal approval to run the test
and must prove that they meet the
quality standards required
they must have qualified technicians and
the lab has to be very
very clean because any amount of
contamination can ruin the test
and with bureaucratic obstacles in the
way of many labs trying to get federal
approval
there just isn't enough of these labs to
keep up with current demand
each test usually takes about four hours
once a sample reaches an approved
testing lab
but with transportation time and the
backlogs that have formed
getting a result can take more than a
week and on top of an already
complicated process
was a catastrophic blunder made by the
cdc
on february 5th the cdc began to send
out the coronavirus test kits it had
developed
the only test permitted in the u.s at
that time
but soon after many of the kits were
found to have faulty negative controls
samples known to be negative were
showing a positive result
meaning the tests themselves were
contaminated with the coronavirus
all of the tests had to be recalled and
remade it took the cdc about a month to
fix the problem
a huge delay at a time where there was
no room to have one
it's clear that the u.s could have been
more prepared but even if they had been
the standard method of pcr testing is
just slow
people want to find out if they have the
virus now not in days or weeks from now
and the only way to achieve this is not
through swabbing and shipping samples to
a few
specialized labs across the country but
through point-of-care testing
sampling testing and getting results on
the spot within
hours or even minutes point of care
testing is already commonplace for other
viruses
doctors regularly run influenza tests in
their offices and can have results back
in around 15 minutes
these types of tests don't detect the
viral genes in a patient sample
instead they look for proteins or
antigens on the surface of the virus
and recently protein-based coronavirus
tests have been developed
and in theory could greatly speed up
testing wait times
if the target coronavirus antigen is
present in a patient's sample
it will bind to specific antibodies
fixed to a paper strip
and generate a visually detectable
signal usually within 30 minutes
these tests are quick and cheap and easy
to do
however while fast they have some
drastic limitations and drawbacks
unlike pcr which amplifies and detects
any amount of viral genetic material in
a sample
protein tests completely rely on how
much viral material is in a single
sample
and you need a lot of virus in a sample
to see a positive signal
the wh reports that the sensitivity of
these tests is likely only between 34
and 80 percent
meaning that half or more of people who
are infected by covid19
who are tested by this method might be
told they are not infected
another point of care testing method is
the antibody or serology test
after a small prick to the finger the
test detects the presence of antibodies
in the blood
using antigens from the virus and thus
can indicate who has already had the
disease and recovered from it
some tests can even be done at home and
results can be given in minutes
but the test doesn't detect the virus
itself only the immune response against
it
thus the tests are useless for
intervention in an infection
but knowing who has already had the
virus and who is likely immune
would still be useful information it
could tell us just how prevalent and
fatal the disease really is
and allow some recovered people to go
back to work
but unfortunately many of the antibody
test kits circulating the world are
being revealed to be extremely
questionable
the uk ordered 3.5 million at-home
antibody tests
only to find the tests were extremely
inaccurate
spain too had to scrap their antibody
testing plan
after tests they ordered were found to
be only 30
accurate and inaccurate tests like this
are not just ineffective
but dangerous the worst possibility is
if you say
okay you're protected people go back to
work thinking that they're protected
and they will end up getting infected
the who does not recommend using
point-of-care protein or
antibody-based testing for patient care
only gene-based tests are sufficiently
accurate and reliable
a gene-based test that can give results
quickly and in any hospital or doctor's
office
would be the best way to manage this
pandemic gene-based or molecular
point-of-care diagnostics do exist
but the field is very young and the
coronavirus outbreak is putting many
biotech companies to the ultimate test
they are rapidly adapting technology to
work for covid19
in the hopes that their tests could be
what solves the testing shortage
these tests use the same basic
methodology as the lab-based test
but automate a number of the steps
involved to make them much quicker and
much more streamlined than lab-based
tests
cepheid is one company that sells small
pcr systems for rapidly detecting
influenza viruses
tuberculosis bacteria and other microbes
they knew that their system could in
theory also test for the coronavirus
with a few adaptations to the technology
but they too had to get fda approval to
be able to do so
by the end of march the approval finally
came in and their tests began to be
rolled out across the country
the test starts with a nasal sample
taken with a swab which is then dropped
into a liquid-filled tube
the liquid containing the sample is then
pipetted into a disposable test
cartridge
and the cartridge is inserted into the
test machine after this the process is
automatic
the sample is then drawn through a
filter which traps any pathogens
then a sonic horn breaks apart the
pathogens and releases their genetic
material
the genetic material is then amplified
with reverse transcriptase
and a positive test will show
fluorescent spikes in the same way as
the pcr method outlined previously
and it can produce results in 45 minutes
the difference between this test and the
traditional pcr test
is its small size and it's largely
automated process
the test can be carried out in any
hospital close to the patient
and the rapid result can inform
healthcare workers what level of care
and isolation the patient requires right
away
the automated process means that minimal
human action is needed to carry out the
test
beyond adding the sample to it this
makes the whole process faster
and reduces the possibility of
contamination which means the test
doesn't require a specially trained
technician
right now there are about 5000 of these
test systems in the us
with more on the way another of these
systems
is called id now it's the size of a
toaster
and can produce results in less than 15
minutes making it the fastest test there
is
it saves time by amplifying nucleic
acids at one temperature
rather than the lengthier process of
thermocycling used in conventional
systems
there are around 18 000 of these units
across the u.s
rapid point-of-care tests like this are
set to become a crucial element of the
widespread testing that can inform
countries
on when to emerge from their lockdowns
in a perfect future
tests like this should exist at airports
train stations and cruise terminals
where there is a high risk of virus
transmission allowing for a quick
response should an outbreak arise
but like everything involving this
pandemic optimism here needs to be
somewhat reserved
a new study reports that some of these
devices may not produce the most
accurate results
they found that id now only detected the
virus in 85.2 percent of positive
samples
meaning it had a false negative rate of
14.8 percent
so 15 out of 100 people would be told
that they're negative for
covid19 when they're actually positive
and that is not good
a good test should be at least 95
accurate
the cepheid test kit faired much better
with a false negative rate of only 1.8
percent
but the study overall calls into
question the accuracy of these tests
which are being rolled out so quickly
and this brings up an extremely
challenging debate about developing and
approving tests
moving too slowly leaving up too much
red tape and an abundance of over
caution has already caused delays that
undoubtedly cost lives
but botched or inaccurate tests can also
be equally if not more devastating
some scientists and regulators argue
that no test is better than a bad test
for the delays and harm they can cause
but others argue that perfect is the
enemy of good
and that any and every amount of testing
now is better than nothing
even if some percentage of the results
are flawed
it is a constant debate a push and pull
of accuracy versus speed
and when the clock is ticking and lives
are at stake doing the right thing at
every turn is essential
but also impossible
[Music]
finding ways we can combat the
coronavirus as a society is at the
forefront of
everyone's minds we anxiously look
towards testing vaccines and viral
treatments
hoping to hear good news that will ease
our lockdown situation
but also marveling at the progress being
made so quickly
i am personally fascinated by the
breakthroughs being made all the time in
the face of this pandemic
like the mrna vaccines i mentioned in
the last video or the rapid pcr machines
that will help
bulk up the testing response a crisis
like this
shows us that necessity is indeed the
mother of invention
and i love the ingenuity that is
cropping up in the scientific community
if you also like learning about these
stories of scientific innovation in the
face of this crisis
or just want to hear some positive news
among so much bad news
you should check out the coronavirus
documentaries on curiosity stream
curiosity stream is a streaming platform
that has thousands of high quality
high budget documentaries like this one
called coronavirus treating the disease
where you can hear from the medical
experts searching for techniques to
treat the illness
and if you're a fan of educational
content and looking for more quality
things to watch during your quarantine
then this is the perfect time to sign up
because a subscription to curiosity
stream now also comes with a
subscription to nebula
nebula is a place where the top
educational content creators
like polyphonic wendover productions and
our other channel real engineering
can create videos freely without
worrying about the youtube algorithm or
demonetization
it's a place where we can upload our
content ad free and also experiment with
original content and new series
the original content is my favorite part
of nebula
shows like the logistics of d-day
working titles or tom scott's game show
money
where he pits a bunch of youtubers
against each other in psychological
experiments where they can work together
or profit individually so if you sign up
for curiosity stream with the link in
the description
you'll get one month of curiosity stream
free and get a free nebula subscription
and for a limited time curiosity stream
is offering their documentary distancing
discount which gives you 40
off all their annual plans and gift
cards so go to curiositystream.com
real science sign up it's a great way to
support this channel and all your
favorite educational content creators
thanks for watching and if you would
like to see more from me the links to my
instagram twitter and patreon are below
you